hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
arguably the most famous idea
or construct of thomas hobbes in
philosophy as a whole is his depiction
of what he calls the
state of nature which is also
a state of war in leviathan and you find
it in
chapter 13 one of the most
anthologized portions of that quite
voluminous
text and in it he depicts the human
being
in our very nature as
driven by antagonism with
other fellow human beings and unable to
enjoy a common life together
there are ways out of this but that goes
beyond the scope of what we're going to
talk about
here we want to look at this
natural condition and what its limits
are
and how deep down it it goes
so the first thing to talk about is that
hobbes depicts this natural state
as one where something is missing
something that we
eventually develop as human beings and
that
is some sort of authority who has
a at least not not necessarily a
complete monopoly
but at least a hegemony of force an
ability to use force against those
who disobey the authority and because
there's no authority there's also no
functional moral norms
acknowledged within this not even
society
but rather just bunch of people spread
out
across a land a territory
whatever it may be and
hobbes goes on to tell us
that at the very beginning there's a
certain basic
equality between human subjects between
human beings and obviously he's engaging
in a good bit of abstraction
because you can say well you know what
we see
are families and groups and clans and
whatever
uh and there's children and you know not
everybody
is actually equal with each other within
these structures either physically
or mentally and ham says well yeah sure
and he talks about you know
raising children later on and the family
household and all that but putting that
aside
if you go along with him he says that
nature has made
men so equal in the faculties of body
and mind
that though there be found one man
sometimes manifestly stronger in body
or of quicker mind than another when all
is
reckoned together the difference between
man and man is not so considerable
as that one man can there upon claim to
himself any benefit
to which another may not pretend as well
as he
now that's important he's not saying you
see that
any of us are totally the same as
everybody else
as a matter of fact there could be great
differences in intellect but
you can say is it a difference that
makes a difference
in the state of nature no why not
well he tells us that
here we go as to the strength of the
body the weakest has strength enough
to kill the strongest either by secret
machination
or confederacy with others that are in
the same danger as himself so you can
have some big
you know tough guy out there as a matter
of fact what we what we do know is that
in
like states of nature like this big
muscle guys don't actually survive very
long
right it's the skinny uh wiry people who
actually live a lot longer but let's say
we have some goliath that he's you know
tromping around and
you know taking people's stuff well
they'll just kill him in asleep
or they'll get together and and do him
in
as a group or they'll poison him or
they'll find some other way
to deal with him right and then he says
as to the faculties of the mind setting
a site
setting aside arts grounded on words and
especially that skill of proceeding upon
general and infallible rules called
science with which
very few have and but in a few things
as not being a native faculty he says i
find yet
a greater equality among men than that
of strength for prudence
is but experience equal time equally
bestows on all men
in those things which they equally apply
themselves to
and now again he's abstracting
this is somewhat plausible we can
probably think of some counter
objections he actually
considers some objections that one might
raise
um you know saying that uh you know
this is this equality is incredible and
then he says well
that's just because people see their own
wisdom
close up and other people's far away so
they think their own is better
he doesn't actually consider people
cases
where people think that they're not as
smart as somebody else but i think
hobbes could have well argued that sort
of case
too so what is the upshot of this
he says from this equality of ability
ariseth equal equality of hope in the
attaining of our ends
so everybody in the hobsean point of
view
is driven by passions by desires
by aversions we want some things we
don't want other things
we're continually driven by these and
figuring out how to get them so one of
the things that we
often do is we see things in the
environment or that other people have
and we're like that's a good thing good
thing for me
i want that i want to take that and so
he says
if any two people desire the same thing
which nevertheless they cannot both
enjoy
they become enemies so now we're getting
into the sources of
human conflict this is you know
hobbs way of addressing a really
important question you could say well
why
if we live in a state of nature why do
we have to fight with each other
why can't we get along why can't we come
to some sort of
you know basic agreement why can't we
rely on
a kind of native instinct
of sympathy or associability hobbs says
well
you may have that stuff but these
sources of conflict are going to do you
in
they're going to override that and so
competition
is a very important one he says in the
way to their end
which is primarily their own
conservation and sometimes their
delectation that is pleasure or
enjoyment only
they endeavor to destroy or subdue one
another
and hence it comes to pass that where an
invader has no more to fear
than another man's single power if one
plant or
so build or possess a convenient seat
others may probably be expected to come
prepared with forces united
to dispossess and deprive him not only
of the fruit of his labor
but also his life or liberty and the
invader again is in like danger of
another so
the idea here is that you know single
people
or you know groups of people they see
what we've got we have to
worry that they're going to come and
take our stuff and
you know we're likely if we're in the
same situation
to go and take their stuff as well and
we might just you know not just take
their possessions
but also their freedom or their very
lives
in the process so this is one main
source of conflict
competition he calls it now that leads
us into the second one
if i know that you
are likely to attack me
because you're motivated by this this
competition or perhaps motivated by
vanity
and i know the attack is coming sooner
or later
then if i'm thinking strategically i had
better
attack you before you can get me and
you are also going through the same
thought process so he says from this
diffidence meaning you know this this
concern about the danger posed by
another there is no way for any man to
secure himself so reasonable as
anticipation so this is the second
source
that is by force or wiles to master the
persons of all men he can
so long till he see no other power great
enough to endanger him
and this is no more than his own
conservation requires
and is generally allowed and also
because there's some that taking
pleasure in contemplating their own
power
in acts of conquest if others that
otherwise would be glad to be
at ease within modern modest bounds
should not by invasion increase their
power they would not be able long time
by standing only on their defense
to subsist so you know we
take action to protect ourselves and as
the old saying goes a good defense is a
good offense right
so we take the offense and attack
subjugate kill others to spoil them
other properties because they were going
to do the same to us they would do the
same to us
in you know if they if roles were
reversed and this leads to larger and
larger groups of people that are held
together essentially by
fear and by perhaps reward as well
so if we only had those two
things would already be fairly grim for
us wouldn't they
hobbes points out another feature of
human
nature and social life that makes it
still more dangerous and problematic and
he calls this vanity
so he tells us men have no pleasure
in keeping company where there's no
power able to overrate them all where
there's no
you know as he's going to call it
sovereign for every man
looks that his companion should value
him
at the same rate he sets upon himself so
we each of us
wants to be valued at a certain rate and
we do get valued
at a certain rate by other people but
those certain rates may not be
equal right so i want you to think that
i am the best
lecturer ever and i'm so smart right and
then you know it's up to you
whether you do say that or not maybe in
a comment you're like this guy's dumb
you know and then i'm like oh
angry uh he's he's transgressing against
me he is peaking
my vanity right or maybe i say something
derogatory
about you as a an audience
and you're like oh i don't like that
right now you're ready to fight with me
so we all want to be valued and we
that's not the big problem there we all
want to be valued at the rate that we
place upon ourselves
not the rate that other people are
willing to give us so what happens when
they don't give us
the rate that we're looking for he says
upon all signs of contempt or
undervaluing
each person naturally endeavors as far
as they
dare to extort a greater value from
their contenders by
damage and from others by the example so
we we attack those
who don't treat us in the way that we
want who don't honor us who don't
respect us
and that makes this you know if this is
a powder keg
that is quite often uh the proverbial
match
that sets it off isn't it so we put all
three of these together
and we've got a pretty dangerous and
difficult situation
so you know hobbs says so long as
there's no as he calls it common power
to over awe them all to to you know make
all of them
essentially fall in line we are as he
says
in a state of war a condition which is
called war and he says
this is a war as is of every man
against every other man so all against
all
at least potentially because you could
say well wait a second what about
worrying about you know people you know
forming a a tribe or confederacy
or pac and then attacking me okay well
that's temporary and
as soon as things break down between
them like you know if they don't get
valued at the rate that they want they
break apart into
uh war as well so it's all against all
anybody could turn against anybody
and he says that war is not just battle
only or the act of fighting but
attractive time wherein the will to
contend by battle is sufficiently known
so you know the nature of fall weather
is not a shower or two of rain but an
inclination
thereto of many days together so the
nature of war consists not in actual
fighting but the known disposition too
so long as i have to worry about you and
everybody else
having these motives uh and and some of
those motives reflect my own motives
we are in a state of war um
what's the result of this so this is
where we get to that famous passage
he tells us that the life of man is
solitary poor
nasty brutish and short why
well because you can't actually develop
much of anything within
a state of war you can't rely
on keeping the things that you have he
says in
such a condition there's no place for
industry because the fruit thereof is
uncertain so there's
no culture of the earth no navigation
nor use of the commodities that may be
imported by sea no commodious building
no instruments of moving and removing
such things as require much force
no knowledge of the face of the earth no
account of time no arts no letters no
society
and what is worse continual fear and
danger of violent death
okay this is a pretty grim picture and
you know again he is idealizing here
because
obviously even the people in the things
that he considers the state of war have
those
those things but it's it's you know you
can get the point it's pretty bad
right so what's really key to this as he
says a little bit later
there is no law there's no recognized
effective moral norms for what counts as
right and wrong people can use these
words if they want to but they don't
have
any real force he says
to this war of every man against every
man this also is consequent
nothing can be unjust the notions of
right
and wrong justice and injustice have
there no place right
so this is this is a you know serious
problem isn't it um the last thing we
have to consider
does hob thinks that this actually
exists and he does bring up
uh the example of native americans
he claims very implausibly the savage
people in many places of america except
the government of small families
that concord whereof depended on natural
lust have no government at all and live
at this day in that british manner as
i've said before and you could say well
okay so this is bad ethnography
and and you know sort of early on
uh eurocentrism hobbs is wrong about
that
but he also brings up two other very
interesting things and one of these
shows what the real
upshot of this is for him one is he says
listen
if you don't believe this is the case
then why do you guard against crime
within our own society which in fact
does have laws and rules he says do you
not accuse mankind as much by your
actions as i do
by my word uh words yeah so he says
you know when you go out on a journey
you arm yourself you seek to go well
accompanied
when going to sleep you lock your doors
even in your house you lock your chests
and you do this even when there are laws
and public
officers right so what do you actually
think of your fellow citizens you you
kind of think
that they would rob you if they had the
chance he also talks about and this is
you know the i think where he's really
aiming
about civil breakdown and war he says
that
it may be perceived what manner of life
there would be where there were no
common power to fear
by the manner of life which men that
have formerly lived under a peaceful
government
used to degenerate into in a civil war
this is actually hobbes reality he is
talking about the
english civil war in which there was
such a breakdown
and um you know there's other examples
that he could bring up
as well we talk in our own time about
you know failed states
things like that and that would be going
back to
a hobbesian state of nature
in which these sources of conflict are
going to inevitably
if not produce conflict at every moment
certainly produce a situation
in which conflicts will rather
unpredictably break out
and in which we can't rely upon our
fellow
citizens residents whatever they happen
to be
and in which we have to live in
continual
fear so then the question is well how do
we get out of this
state of nature
you